good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-2102
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
scp-2102
is to be housed at site 122 in an l-type
humanoid anomaly containment cell hacc
for short this is to be modified to
minimize the probability of injury to
scp-2102
scp-2102 is to remain fully restrained
at all times with its hands and feet
encased within padded sleeves to avoid
accidental or intentional lacerations of
its epidermis
scp-2102 was to be considered a
permanent class alpha red security risk
in light of its suicidal tendencies
in case of an unbounded ectoentropic
reaction uer for short all on-site
personnel not specifically attached to
this project are to be evacuated and
three members of security staff with at
least l2 2102 clearance are to enter
scp-2102 cell to initiate its breach
protocol c2102 prt breach 14 av 1.2 for
more information following the incident
scp-2102
is to be treated by attached level 3
medical staff for any burns sustained
during the incident excess tissue is to
be excised and the resulting wounds are
to be cauterized immediately this is
currently the only reliable way to
reduce the amount of tissue generated
excised tissue is to be destroyed as per
the standard biohazard disposal protocol
if its breach protocol fails all site
122 personnel with level 3 security
clearance have been provided with the
pass key to this project's kill switch
this can be activated remotely and doing
so will trigger the dispersal of a
dicyano acetylene gas and powdered
fluoridated aluminum within scp-2002's
containment cell this mixture will be
ignited automatically after a three
second delay if the kill switch is not
successful in deactivating scp-2102
no further provisions have been made
description
scp-2102 is an unidentified male of
indeterminate age and descent
scp-2102 measures approximately 178
centimeters in length and weighs an
estimated 48 kilograms one hundred
percent of
scp-2102's body is covered in
hypertrophic scars as a result of the
application of its breach protocol in
order to halt past uer 2002 events due
to this scarification
scp-2102 is deaf mute and blind
and cannot be interviewed all data on
scp-2102 was gathered from testing and
from surviving gru division p
documentation
scp-2102's anomalous properties manifest
when it suffers a puncture wound or
laceration initiating an anomalous wound
healing process designated a uer 2102
event this process is instantaneous and
though both hemostatic and inflammatory
phases occur as normal the proliferative
phase of the process occurs at a greatly
increased rate and no wound contraction
occurs during a uer 2102 event
scp-2102 will continue to produce new
tissue at an exponential rate unless all
open wounds are successfully cauterized
based on this it is estimated that the
culmination of an nk class scenario
would occur approximately four weeks
post event should full neutralization
not be achieved tissue generated during
uer 2102 events will expand into any
available open space obstructions are
able to delay the expansion but as more
tissue is generated it will exert a
mounting pressure on materials currently
there is no upper limit to the mpa
scp-2102 is able to generate
blunt force trauma that does not break
scp-2102's epidermis will not induce its
anomalous properties and the application
of intense heat will cauterize any open
lacerations halting
scp-2102's anomalous wound healing tests
have also indicated that scp-2102's
anomalous properties would in all
probability not persist if all soft
tissues were destroyed
addendum 2102 a1
notes on recovery and preliminary
containment
scp-2102 was recovered from the grounds
of the institute of experimental
medicine csav in
czechoslovakia on 12 2
1972. foundation agents embedded in the
czechoslovakian government had been
aware of the existence of a gru division
p project housed on the grounds of the
institute since earlier that year and
intelligence reports indicated its focus
to be on the development of practical
applications for rapid cellular
regeneration following the successful
appropriation of classified
documentation detailing
scp-2102 and its anomalous properties a
recovery operation was planned for
january 1973.
on 1202 1972 at 714 utc gmt a
disturbance was reported at the
institute of experimental medicine csav
and a large number of civilians were
seen fleeing the premises a small
foundation reconnaissance force
comprised of members from several mobile
task forces stationed in eastern europe
was immediately dispatched to take stock
of the situation before recovery was
initiated preliminary containment was
affected at 2301 utc gmt on 1202 1972
permanent containment on 12 13 1972
addendum 2102 a2
excerpts from reconnaissance log 2102 op
rec 721202
merrick what is your location on the
grounds nearing the entrance to the
bunker looks like it's wide open
no hostels inside copy that
you're cleared for approach good luck
moving in
the smell is
off here
can't put my finger on it jones stop
bumble [ __ ] and watch that left
hallway
jesus mostly labs and offices
found what looks like a break room a
while back
most of the files are gone and what they
left doesn't look important
just paperwork on shipments food
supplies standard logistical stuff
take it anyway let ia figure it out
any sign of the anomaly yet
roger will do
no sign of the anomaly so far but it
might be on minus two or lower ashton
start grabbing every scrap of paper you
can see
keep your eyes peeled merrick copy
vacuum here
almost done on -1 still no sign of the
anomaly smells getting worse though
we've located an elevator to the lower
levels we'll keep you posted we copy
merrick proceed with caution always
jones ashton we're going down i want you
to secure
wait
command
any seismic activity in this area
not that we know of merrick
why
i think i just felt something move down
here
come in command
elevator's stuck
we went down maybe about a foot before
we hit something no idea
what's that sound
[Applause]
[Music]
come in merrick what is your status
[Applause]
we managed to open the doors and climb
out we've got an unknown amorphous mass
coming up from the lower levels
recommend immediate counter measures
copy that merrick we have two f-4s on
standby
they'll be with you in approximately
seven minutes can you hold out i have no
[ __ ] clue come on right now we're
trying every trick in the book but every
time we damage it it seems to grow more
rapidly ashton see what a couple lemons
do to that thing
command i hope those words you said and
have something up more that'll stick
because nothing more carrion seems to be
stopping this thing don't worry the guys
in ia said they know how to deal with
this get your team out of there merrick
got me
there status merrick we're okay but this
thing just exploded through the top soil
and it's still growing
those birds better get here fast eta
approximately six minutes how fast is it
moving
get out of there merrick what's going on
we lost jones he just got sucked under
that thing i have no idea what his speed
is and i don't care get those birds here
now
at 1422 utc gmt two f4 phantoms dropped
their payload of m47a1
napalm incendiary bombs successfully
cauterizing the tissue generated by
scp-2102
during its uer 2102 event in progress
addendum 2102 a3
translated excerpts from captured gru
division p documentation
the following selected diary entries
were found amongst paperwork recovered
from the institute of experimental
medicine csav their author could not
definitively be determined
date 2nd of march
1972.
finally arrived i swear the tupolev was
shaking more than the bmp i rode in
during my service the equipment crates
were already there and mostly intact
though too
chambers anna ronkin got mashed a bit on
the train and the mainframe looks rather
unwell too i met with the local staff i
kept hearing such things about comrade
director chanyee their head of research
has some genuinely compelling ideas
about test subject suitability index
based on basal metabolic rate the minsk
experiments and a couple other things
though that might have been the result
of his barack polinka
date 3rd of march 1972
turns out our and their three-phase
plugs are somewhat different
i have a headache
date 5th of march 1972.
good news me mikhail kuzma and their
technician przynovsky managed to swap
the leads on everything and fix up the
broken kit with the spares he managed to
dig out from somewhere all of it works
too bad news as soon as we plugged in
all of it for a test run the fuses blew
and we knocked out the power from half
the institute i would have thought they
prepared things to our specification
ugly news looking through their fusing
diagrams it took three of us half the
day to sort it out whoever drew these up
should be scrubbing the cellars of the
libyanka
at least we will have time to go
sightseeing there's a pretty amazing
castle ruin nearby and since comrade
orokova's sister works there we can go
for a private tour still the project
stagnating for reasons this stupid
leaves a bitter aftertaste
date 19th of april 1972.
it took a couple chats with the onv
board the institute's director and one
angry call to moscow but we had the
power grid strengthened in record time
take that watliam weber
in other news they brought in a couple
promising candidates today not ideal by
far but we'll have to work with what we
have soon we will see if the theories
are correct ps the trip was a blast got
maroosh a scarf she'll love too and
what's better entire stock equals about
a kilo of chewing gums all it took was a
roll of rubles to the shopkeeper
date 5th of may 1972
the first subject looked promising at
first when we introduced trauma rapid
clotting took place as expected but the
process aborted soon enough and lesions
developed turns out mikhail mixed in far
too much neodymium the oaf i swear this
is the last straw i told him if he [ __ ]
up again i will drag his ass to moscow
by his collar
date 28th of june 1972
why do they keep dying it doesn't make
sense reducing the amount of neodymium
actually made the necrosis worse i
cannot tell mikael that or i will be
hearing it for the rest of my life
date 3rd of august 1972
the cultivation is done and elena dr
elena or of kova current whereabouts
unknown had a look at the histology the
results are
interesting almost like an equilibrium
of sorts the cells divide 50 times
faster than in control samples but they
die off almost immediately too until the
whole thing chokes on its waist so to
say it's not pretty it seems that to
make this work we need to shift that
balance somehow
date 15th of august 1972.
so he got another candidate the 16th
since the start of the project i'd gone
to slizzard dr slizzard chonyi see
documentation on operation redemption
and told him we really needed someone
more resilient than normal people the
ministry came through from what we heard
we got ourselves a counter-revolutionary
who spent 15 years in a uranium mine as
punishment detail and somehow came out
fine sure enough histology results
pointed his cells pulling a koshi the
deathless and his natural regeneration
is about twice as fast as your average
man too who knows
this might be the one
date fifth is september 1972
preliminary results looking good the
wound healing process does not abort
anymore though perhaps it is completing
a bit too rapidly i cannot believe i
just wrote that
i wonder if we can redefine the process
and perhaps even make it permanent it
was not our original goal but
if we manage this
date 24th of september 1972.
i'm finding it increasingly difficult to
sleep x16 is not like the others he's
not weak the others never lasted for
more than one cycle but x-16 has been
lacerated so many times now and each
time he survives today he somehow freed
himself from the restraints and
attempted to slit his wrists i should be
happy because it means the effect now
lasts several hours longer than we
expected but i cannot help but feel bad
for him i need some time off maybe
slizzard will let me go see maruscia
date 15th of october 1972.
finally we have found the right
composition it turns out we needed a
little more of that stabilizing agent
juridge introduced a few weeks ago it
was staring us in the face all this time
subject x-16 is responding well in the
medical sense at least he is as
uncooperative as ever it doesn't matter
it will be done and over soon another
little step towards our victory when you
think of it the man is a hero and he
doesn't even know it
date 3rd of november 1972.
elena showed up in my section of the lab
just as i was preparing another batch of
this serum she looked distraught and
practically dragged me off by the sleeve
good reason too
long story short the samples seem to be
gaining mass from nowhere she thought it
was a measurement error but i got the
same after spending the day calibrating
the machines i'm very worried
i got into an argument with slizzard and
juridge they say it's bound to be an
error and want to press on while i and
elena want to look deeper into what the
hell is happening
date 26th of november 1972.
there is a pattern to the increases in
mass and
all over and it's not just x-16 now i
feel the answer is at my grasp i had it
all worked out yesterday but i woke up
at my desk soon after i really need more
sleep
maruscia i miss her but slizzard is not
about to let me go
date 27th of november 1972.
we were ordered to stop working on
sample analysis and focus on empirical
tuning of the composition me and elena
appear to be the only ones with an ounce
of common sense here
just a few days more
date 2nd of december
1972. it's far too early to be up but i
cannot sleep today is the day we either
produce the very first super soldier or
we start over with nothing i really do
not know which is better
tomorrow is a day too
there are no later entries in the diary
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all
dismissed goodbye
[Music]
i would like to give a special thank you
to
allah trayon
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
jk
signor
your local foundation agent derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
scio dio demnaris
eric corbige
longinus
karim l ashmoy
james saba
and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vulgan
thank you
you